if i had infinity powers like i have
infinite powers
and i could give you the perfect life
okay i i mean literally
whatever was perfect for you moment to
moment because i had
infinite powers i could adjust it i
could it's just infinity what i can do
for you
no limit except for me to do that
i have to say have you signed a piece of
paper and that paper is going to have me
take your brain out of your skull and
put it in your
float in a vat your brains are going to
be floating in the vat you're not going
to know you're the brand of the bad
because you're going to be having the
perfect life right
whatever that is it's right perfect at
all times
sign up but my brain's gone your brain's
in the vat brain's in the vat and having
the perfect life there's floating there
having the perfect flag
wow
and if not no yeah why not
because forgo the perfect existence
because i want to experience it well
you're experiencing that
because i have infinity powers infinite
i can make you feel like you're
experiencing it
you are experiencing as far as you know
but i think there's something in what
that i want to experience a
thing what is it you want to experience
that you can't experience
for some of the tough parts i guess i
have infinity powers i can do all that
i can do everything anything can be good
whatever infinity
i want control i gotta give you control
i give you i have infinite powers
there's one thing i can't do though
there's only by virtue of you being a
brain in the vat there's
one and only one thing because of that
circumstance
that i can't do you can't be me
i can't have you exist to other people
anymore
you cease to exist to other people wow
you don't know that right but you have
to sign up to cease to exist
and most humans won't do that that's how
important other people are to us we
would forego the perfect existence we
don't know why we wouldn't sign up
but we all have this instinct like i
sign up it's because
you leave the people you love you won't
exist to them you'll
you know they'll obviously have their
grief and whatever but you really won't
exist
and so even if you're if your role in
your perfect existence is to go
save humanity you can save humanity as
the brain of the vat and you will have
done exactly nothing
wow because you won't exist it's the
same thing that scares it's the same
moment that used to scare me about dying
all the time it would be that moment
where
[ __ ] i won't exist i won't exist at all
but in at least the brain of the bat
you'll think you exactly right oh the
brain in the vat sounds beautiful it's
better than dying
but i mean basically i just want to be a
server to baskin robbins but we're shut
down because of weather and so i get
everything
that's really i guess that's what you'll
be
i imagine if some anybody ever signed up
for that if there were if there ever
were such a thing
i wanted to read a script one time where
i was thinking if we could you know
something goes wrong i've got somebody's
brain on the vent something goes wrong i
have to go
in and meet him on his in his brain of
the bat land
and and i just imagine he's just
somebody just eating people
[ __ ] on them like westworld right
right
i imagine that's what happened i'm just
sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been